today brings us a report on developer I
dos Montreal and the deus ex series are
those games going on hiatus what's the
team working on next I'm Tony and this
game spot news update should hopefully
clear things up Eurogamer reports that
the deus ex series is currently on
hiatus this makes sense since itís
Montreal is developing games for
publishers Square Enix's new partnership
with Marvel you may recall the recent
Avengers game teaser we got last week
eurogamer's sources say the studio is
currently working on an untitled
guardians of the galaxy game which is
currently in very early stages kotaku
editor jason schreier back this up with
a tweet of his own so we'll see what
happens next square enix's partnership
with Marvel is for quote multiple
ongoing projects and we're supposed to
hear more in 2018 but if you're in the
mood for more comic book goodness in the
meantime check out our seven crazy comic
book crossovers on gamespot universe and
for all the latest on square I dos and
marble games you're already in the right
place
you